- Zack always goes, "I'm a man!"
- "Oh, that's fantastic!"
- They should call this
video "Before the fight."
- We have been together
for like almost two years.
- [Woman] Since October.
- [Man] October.
- My impression of her has been honed
over the past five years.
I think it's pretty good.
- We have the same mannerisms.
- [Ned] Yeah.
- We finish each other's
sentences all the time--
- Sentences!
- He's going to be so much better than me,
because he's so observant.
- "Oh gosh, I don't know."
- "What's up. My name is Zack."
"Oh, man. Today's just nuts, am I right?"
- "I'm Kevin McShane,"
it's a little nasal.
- I don't sound like an anchorman.
- "Oh my God, I'm so tired
and I have so much work to do.
"But I don't know if I'm
ready to go to sleep yet."
That's every sentence from her.
- When she gets really excited
she starts lisping a little bit.
"I'm so excited!"
- When she's embarrassed, she just goes,
"Oh my gosh!"
- When you get, like, really excited,
you kinda almost don't
finish your sentences.
- "I'm going to be a
robot and talk like this,"
"and this is my mechanical voice."
- "Hey, brah. Hey brah, you lifting?"
"You mad?"
- I don't do that.
- You know when she's
drunk, that's for sure.
Not because she's like
belligerent or anything,
but just because the eyes kind of like...
- "Baby, I got dollars, I got
bills, I can pay for this."
"I do not care. I got money to blow!"
- "Listen, listen, I love you so much."
"No, just, no, no."
- "I'm Jake, guys, I'm making a big joke."
"You should laugh!"
And it's like really this
like weird big personality.
- I'll hear the word, "Baby" a lot.
Like, "Baby, hi!"
And her biggest thing is
she just talks to everyone,
and everyone's her best friend.
- We'll be at a party and you'll be like,
"This is my boyfriend. Isn't he cute?"
"He's the cutest, you guys."
"He's the cutest."
And then if you have like
two more drinks you're like,
"Get out of here!"
- Um, we haven't fought, really.
- That's a lie.
- We never fight, and then
six months, he'll be like,
"Back in August, this..."
and I'm like, "The summer?"
- You have this thinking face that you get
if you're really concentrating,
you start going like this.
- "I just, I just need your support."
- That's not true!
That was one time.
- She'll say things like,
"For crying out loud."
Or, "Oh my gosh." Like, "Oh, okay."
- "Well, I mean, you know, whatever."
"And this, that and the other thing."
And then if you're drunk,
it's like, "Get out of here!"
"No one likes you."
- Kevin likes to give me lap dances.
But then he does the white man's overbite,
so it's like...
Do the white man's overbite.
- You know you like it.
- Oh, oh the stank face, oh
the stank face, he goes--
- Yeah, that's what you forgot.
- "Long hair, she don't care, ooh."
- Ned goes crotch first.
So he's like...
- Yeah!
- Doing a lot of like, repetitive, like,
there's a lot of this,
and there's a lot of this.
- She dances like an
overexcited school teacher.
There's a lot of...
And then...
- She's dancing and she's
going, "There she go."
She goes, "There she
goes, there she goes."
That's half of her dancing,
is her, like, commen--
- Commentary, that's it.
- Ariel leads with her butt.
- That was so good.
- I'm okay with it.
- Wait, I'm actually really proud of that.
- It's harder than I expected.
- I think I was more on
than I thought I'd be.
- I nailed it.
- And he starts like,
hanging on people like this.
- I'm not, like, sloppy.
- He's a drunk girl.
- I'm not, what?